I hate intros my hero academia episode 1
we jump right into some action with
little majority as trying to protect one
of his classmates from Baca go who's
bullying him that doesn't go so well and
we get a little backstory on the
universe
the first quirk that was discovered was
a glowing baby and after that more and
more started showing up but nobody knows
the origin back over to mediodía who
dreams of becoming a hero so he takes
extensive notes in his notebook about
all the heroes he's come across in
school we find out that biker guy was
going to go to UA which is a high
ranking Hero school and also we're mean
DoDEA is hoping to attend ever since he
was a kid we thought he had been a huge
fan of all might the number-one hero and
his inspiration for wanting to become a
hero
unfortunately he finds out from a doctor
that he's not gonna develop any quirks
which is devastating to young melodia
back to the present a slime monster
recreates a common hentai scene with the
help of mediodía
all my had been pursuing the slime
monster and blossom oi with the wind
pressure from his punch he hits me dodea
with a preemptive autograph and then
dips but my daughter had some questions
so he just kind of tags along all might
seems to be in a hurry but me Dodie
wants to know if it's possible to become
a hero without any parents which grabs
his attention Yepez oh - well me thought
he is telling all my that he wants to be
a hero or like him all might deflates
into what appears to be a method after
defeating the sludge monster he put him
into a bottle and was taking him to the
police while he was jumping through the
air with me Dodie ain't oh he had
dropped the bottle [ __ ] you go just so
happy to be walking by the bottle and
kicks it releasing the sludge monster
who targets baka go back over to
Almighty who's explaining that he was
severely injured in a fight with a
villain five years ago now he can only
maintain his muscle form in five
villains for three hours a day before he
reverts to his meth state he tells me
the idea that you can't become a hero
without powers and recommends that he
becomes a police officer instead
casually dashing his dreams while
walking down the stairs he notices that
he dropped the bottle and sees commotion
in the distance hop on over to baka go
who's being consumed by the sludge
monster and none of the heroes on the
scene have quarks capable of stopping
this lunch me thirty against there and
he sees the sludge monster and he starts
to blame himself because he feels like
he's the reason that almighty had
dropped the bottle oh my he's watching
from the back of the crowd as well but
can't muster the power to transform as
soon as me though dia realizes that the
hostage was actually buck ago he runs it
without thinking to help him he used his
backpack toss which cuts the monsters
eye buying Baku go some oxygen and time
he they're desperately cloths at the
sledge to get back you go free which
inspires all my to transform even though
it's gonna be detrimental to his health
he one tapsa monster saving Baku go
ahead me DoDEA well walking home all my
catches up with me the idea and changes
this answer from before saying that he
can't become a hero the episode three we
find out that the public
always considered almighty power
something along the lines of super
strength but in reality it's a power
passed down from one person to the next
each cultivating it all might have been
looking for a successor for sometime and
when me Dottie had tried to say buck you
go that convinced all might that he
would be a good choice all my powers
called one for all Amy Dodi has to train
his body otherwise it's gonna break his
limbs he meets with all my on a beach
where people frequently dump their trash
and his tasked with the insane ten month
schedule of clearing the trash he works
hard for the ten months and on the
morning of the entrance exam he finishes
cleaning up the last of the beach the
last step is see one of all my tears to
complete the transfer apparently it just
had to be some sort of DNA which made me
think well how does he prevent it from
being passed down to one of his fangirls
unless he just doesn't date any girls
and at that point you could just keep
her powers I wouldn't want it I just
stay a muggle and go find a girl with
daddy issues well any your eyes that you
a he almost trips and falls but I say
fine new waifu Canada Oh chucka Oh
chucka well I'm glad you enjoyed that
because apparently you can't do anything
else with them we also meet Enya Ito who
scolds me DoDEA for muttering during the
orientation each person is assigned a
battle center and once inside the
applicants have to defeat as many robots
as they can there are three different
types of robots which give you points
for defeating them the fourth type is
more of an obstacle robot and won't
yield any points so their advice to
avoid it in the last scene mediodía gets
to his battle center and the test is
about to commence the episode for at the
beginning of the event when he runs into
his first robot he freezes and you got
Yama chaos is it he soon falls behind
the others who are racking up the points
when he is still at zero the obstacle
robot is then released which is a
massive robot that all of the applicants
are forced to run from me thodi apropos
to flee - but then he sees Ithaca pinned
down by some rubble instincts take over
and he uses one for all to jump into the
air and one-shot the giant robot of
course he didn't really think this all
the way through because now his limbs
are broken and he's free-falling with no
way to stop right before he hits the
ground he gets slapped by Erica so she
can activate her power and make him
float which saves him from the fall then
she proceeds to vomit right as the
timer's reaching zero ending the test
without mediodía scoring a single point
the school nurse recovery girl drowns
first base the hills limbs and makes him
good as new later on he gets a hologram
message from UA which is actually all my
explaining that he had come to town to
work for you eh
all my also shows him that uh tadaka had
come in after the test that asked for
permission to give him some of her
points since he saved her as it turns
out she didn't have to because there was
a hidden scoring system that gave
applicants rescue points both him and
Udo daca accumulated enough points to
pass a test and get accepted into UA
episode 5 now that me DoDEA made it into
UA he goes to his first class where he
finds out that vodka go and eda are both
there which are the two he was trying to
avoid although there is the consolation
prize of vodka being in his class as
well they meet their homeroom teacher
Eraserhead who takes him outside to put
them through a series of tests to find
out where they stand with their quirks
whoever finishes lesson the test is
gonna be expelled so everybody starts
taking it a little bit more seriously
everybody seems to be able to utilize
their work and at least one of the tests
so Midori ends up in last the ball throw
test is gonna be the last one that me
DoDEA can affect the outcome of with his
quirk so he decides that he's gonna go
all-out Eraserhead steps in and
nullifies his quirk before he can use it
and says that he can't become a hero if
he has to be saved every time he uses
his power so my authority of focus is
one for all into a single finger so that
when he throws the ball it breaks his
finger but at least he isn't out of
commission afterwards episode six
Miko dia threw the ball over 700 meters
but the tests after that didn't go so
well because he was in so much pain from
his finger since he didn't do that well
on the remaining tests he finishes in
last place but a racer had said that he
was actually lying about the expulsion
while walking back all my calls out of
racer had saying that he doesn't joke
about these kind of things and last year
he expelled an entire class the reason
he didn't expel me DoDEA is because he
saw potential in him oh my is gonna be
leaving their next class and the
students get their super suits me
thought he had never applied for a suit
so he does I have one but his mom had
made one based off of a sketch from his
notebook they're gonna be doing indoor
combat training with teams going
head-to-head with one another each team
has two students with one team acting as
villains that have to protect a fake
bomb the opposing team are heroes who
either have to secure the bomb or
apprehend the villains miqo'te has
teamed up with Rebecca and they're first
up as heroes against Baku go and EDA on
the villain team when they go inside the
test building baka go ambushes both of
them but midoriya counters taking him
down we thought he has taken extensive
notes on all the heroes he admired
including Baku go so he's able to
predict his moves he can't use one for
all about kugo because he can't control
it yeah and he might end up killing him
episode 7 we go da continues predicting
Baku goes moves and eventually runs away
to try to get to it a rocket to team up
on EDA the hero team just has to touch
the bomb for the game to end but EDA is
making sure that you know doc he can't
get to it buck who go finds me though da
again and uses his new suit to shoot an
explosion at it this is like way over
the top so all my friends that if he
does it again he's gonna forfeit the
match
Victoria tries fighting back but in
terms of 1v1 combat he's clearly
outclassed by Bakugan so instead of
going head-to-head with him he uses his
right arm to blow a hole in the floor
above him where Arouca and EDA are
this causes enough confusion for rocket
to use her core can get to the bomb
Methodius left arm also took the full
brunt of baka goes explosion so both of
his arms are completely tattered
afterwards but even though he's crippled
they still managed to secure the victory
episode most of this episode is pretty
much just introducing more of class-one
haze characters during the training we
have Momo yeah go to zoo who can create
pretty much anything she wants with her
work which sounds pretty handy mezzo
Shoji can replicate his body parts on
the tips of his tentacles the hentai
applications are astounding then we have
his teammate Loki and I'm glad they
reworked his character design in the
future seasons cuz he looks like he's
trying to kill Sarah Connor his opponent
was massive algae Doe who has a tail
which is just an unlike your role in
quirks Judah's partner for the test was
total hockey coude who's rocking a
permanent doctor disrespect cosplay I
want to be transparent mixed up is jato
Seto who shoots tape out of his elbows
his femur was Asiatic ADA Shima who can
harden his body parts I'm allergic to
low-hanging fruits I'd rather not milk
that quark their opponents were Fuma
cogito chiami who can summon a shadow to
fight form and also sue Yasui who has
the attributes of a frog and is
responsible for the best cosplay i've
ever seen jump on over to the pervert
Meno to mean that they who spawn stinky
balls on his head in the throes of mad
people
reels I have to go Jenna who has
headphone jacks for ears and can emit
sound attacks
she was teamed up with danke community
who produces electrical attacks running
out of transitions Riki dose at though
eats sugar and turns it into strength
working with him a Scotia Koda whose
timid and beta but then ironically
commands animals and finally me mashido
who can produce acid from her hands back
to the story we find out that the only
ones who know about all mines meth stay
are his close friends recovery girl and
the principle of you a methodius doesn't
want vodka go to feel like he deceived
him so he tells him that he got his
powers from somebody but he can't tell
him who episode 9 the press had found
out that all might had started working
at UA as a teacher and now word is
getting around to everybody else
class 1a is test with assigning your
class representative and after a vote me
Dodie ends up winning well eating in
alarm sounds because of you way sensors
pick up on an intruder all the students
are panicking but EDA figures out that
it was just the press s somehow got
through the outer barriers he's able to
calm all the students down so my
daughter says that he should be the
class rep instead and he gladly accepts
the barrier had been mysteriously
destroyed by somebody and the teachers
speculate that it could be a declaration
of war oh my is noticing that he's been
slowing down a lot since he gave his
power to me DoDEA so when the class goes
for rescue training he's too fatigued to
go we're introduced to the pro hero 13
who was leaving the course but before
can start a bunch of villains are
teleported into the arena
episode 10 the school sensors are being
jammed presumably by a villain so
there's no help coming for this
thirteen stays behind to protect the
students while the racer head goes to
fight the villains head on judogi cuts
off the students escape and announces
that they are the league of villains who
were there to kill all my he uses his
work to separate the students across the
arena so that the trash mobs can pick
them apart me DoDEA ends up in the
shipwreck zone with me Natha and a soui
he comes to the conclusion that they
must have been the ones who destroyed
the barrier and let the press in so that
they could sneak in and gather
information EDA has ordered to use his
speed and go get help while 13 covers
his escape from Cadogan II back over to
me Dougherty and company who are stuck
in a ship with villains surrounding them
me DoDEA does a Power flick that breaks
his thumb and middle finger to blow a
hole in the water giving them the
distraction needed to use at Suey's
court to escape
episode 11 Eraserhead is still fighting
off multiple villains so mediodía wants
to go and see if he can try and help him
he gets where race ahead is but can't
find an opening to help so they end up
just kind of sitting there and watching
Eraserhead police which allows Tomo does
she got hockey the leader in the attack
to activate his core crumbling eraser
heads elbow who nomu steps in and starts
dumpster ink eraser head and he points
out that the nomu is actually as strong
as all my 13 is outsmarted and defeated
by Cadogan Udo Dhaka has to step in to
cover ETA's escape to get help
chikka rocky targets a soui but
Eraserhead manages to get eyes on him
before he could use his quirk Authority
he goes to use one for all and she got a
key and even though he managed to
control his power to prevent his arm
from breaking the Nommo head steps in
front of the punch and absorbed it like
it was nothing and in the last scene all
my finally arrives to join the fight yep
as Oh 12 all might uses his super speed
to get Eraserhead and the kids to safety
from the villains the students are
ordered to get racer head to safety
while all night covers for the retreat
all my punches are negated by the no
move shock absorption so instead he has
to try and use the suplex on it Cadogan
ax uses his work gate to prevent this
from being effective and the nomu goes
for all mites weak spot where he was
injured five years before who no mu is
actually just a distraction to get all
might half waiting takoto goodies warp
gate so that they can shut the gate
cutting all mine in half you go to guess
sees that all might is stuck so he runs
to help right is Baca go Toto rocky and
kid a shame I show up to help in the
fight as well go to it okay freezes to
the no move while Bakr go secure pseudo
godis body who know who gets free and
goes to kill baka go and rescue kudo
agony so all my hands to step in and
save baku go while taking the hit after
that he squares off with the nomu and
punches him in rapid succession until
the shock absorption wears off before it
can regenerate the shock absorption he
throws one last haymaker that launches
the Nommo into the sky leaving chigan
Aki and Canoga D as the only ones left
episode 13 apparently somebody had the
information that all might was getting
weaker and told the league of villains
about it Oh
was pushed to his limits in the fight
with the Nomis and now he's putting on a
show that he's fine antagonizing the
villains and hopes that they retreat
they call his bluff and she gataki
rushes him so media breaks both of his
legs jumping to land a hit on Cody jig
otaku reacts and uses cadogan eats a
teleport his hand in front of my
daughter yeah but before he can use his
quirky stop by the UA teachers who
finally arrived with Edith with the
heroes arriving the villains are forced
to retreat with Cadogan ease warp game
they arrive at a bar where she got Aki's
master is informed of their failure and
says that they're just gonna have to try
again
Arisa added 13 received treatment for
their injuries and are both gonna be
okay the nomer was also fun and did it
resist so the cops take it into custody
where you get a segue scene with media
saying that this attack was just the
beginning of a major incident that
happens later and we get a skewed look
at a new villain this got me thinking
about how the only thing I hate more
than intros is outros